the triangle of sadness
swedish director reuben ocelin shocked
cairne with a graphic 15-minute vomiting
scene in his film triangle of sadness
that picked up his palm door prize with
a message of how we must question
inequality but keep our sense of humor
i'm happy that the jury
acknowledged the film i mean it's it's a
comedy satire so
it's uh it's a kind of film that maybe
not
out of tradition wins that often in khan
and i wanted to do a film where i feel
the audience is engaged and laughing and
participating
at the same time as you have the content
that is thought provoking and that you
need to discuss afterwards triangle of
sadness is a satirical film about
capitalism set on a luxury cruise ship
that later sinks it's a dark comedy
about hierarchy and how it can be
flipped freedom in capitalist society
always remains about the same as it was
in ancient greece freedom
for slave owners i know vladimir lenin
audiences in cannes gave it a standing
ovation for eight minutes winning the
palm door twice which is so rare
um will establish reuben auslan as
perhaps
for many people the greatest living
director working today his films really
touch upon
something that we talk about a lot and
we see especially on social media the
white liberal guilt and his films are
exactly tapping into that sensibility
the grand prix was awarded jointly to
french director claire denis for stars
at noon a romantic thriller set in
nicaragua
and close by belgian director lucas
dante a sensitive coming-of-age film
about the friendship of two 13-year-old
boys whose bond is later torn apart
[Music]
the jury prize was also shared between
eo a gentle film exploring the world
through the eyes of a donkey
eight mountains an epic love letter to
friendship and nature set in the italian
alps
this year cannes has celebrated
storytelling there are no car chases or
special effects in these winning films
just stories well told that remind us of
the power of independent cinema charlie
angela al jazeera